a beautiful morning out there happy st
patrick's day everybody top of the
morning to you uh looks like we've got
some nice clear skies for now and much
lighter winds wanted to share a great
photo from john salvi he's a very loyal
viewer and shoots a lot of great photos
and sends them in this was from the
green up event the las vegas wash over
the weekend you can see the canada geese
excuse me and the ducks all out in the
water having a good time as volunteers
came out to help clean up the las vegas
wash so it really was a fun event over
the weekend
it's really important to take care of
our washes get them cleaned up for all
the wildlife the waterfowl out there a
beautiful morning to be out for a stroll
everybody the winds were a little bumpy
before daybreak and but now they're
doing they're a lot better as we head
towards dawn here in the next few
minutes 54 on the strip 57 at the lakes
55 at aliante 53 in nellis henderson
you're checking in the same in the low
50s low 50s for seven hills but a little
breezy out at red rock though if you
want to head out there for a bike ride
or early morning jog just know the winds
have been up around 20 miles an hour at
times below freezing up in cedar city
cali annie's in the 30s low 50s for
mesquite some mid 50s in boulder city
and we will have some northerly breezes
along the colorado river valley today
it's been a little bumpy in laughlin and
bullhead city temps in the 60s there low
50s for sandy valley mid 40s for indian
springs and prompt right now we're on
our way to very normal temperatures
really we'll slide from mid 70s to low
70s today uh average high for march 17th
is 72 in our final days of winter here
now we're really doing fine in fact
we're going to warm up again even
tomorrow and into the weekend at least
the start of the weekend
we're equal day and equal night 12 hours
of daytime and night time off by only a
minute 6 49 officially the sunrise 6 50
p.m the sunset yesterday's system
brought us some afternoon clouds and a
few little spotty showers to northwest
arizona it's now in the middle of the
country with snow in the rockies showers
in the plains there are thunderstorms on
the east coast and we've got another
system moving into the west coast that
will eventually start bringing more
clouds into the area today so by the
afternoon a mix of sun and clouds low
70s for your st patrick's day we'll get
all the way back to 80 degrees for our
last afternoon of winter but that next
chilly system affects us with a chance
of rain saturday night breezy winds and
we'll be down to 60s for our first
afternoon of spring on sunday with a
slight chance of morning showers and
then on our way to warm 80s next week